ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome to another episode of shimcast
IRL I am so excited to be here with a
number of several guests some of you
have been asking about um guest host Tim
Poole and when he's going to be back he
likes to hang out here with us uh
unfortunately Tim
is a sick man Tim is sick and
he's getting the help that he needs
right now and so we're all just going to
wish him well and and
hope that he gets better soon in all
seriousness he should probably be back
in a few days but technically when I
said he's a sick man there was nothing
factually incorrect about that that is
literally true right I mean I have a
lawyer here who can confirm that nothing
I said was incorrect at this time we
have no further elucidations to add to
your statement thank you very much do
wish to reserve our right to uh
make any additional uh
amendments as might be required yeah
well it's interesting how my first time
ever hosting the show Tim was like we
need to send a lawyer in here just to
fact check him and make sure he stays on
point all night we have a number of
stories tonight the Ocean Gate uh Story
the tragic loss of the Ocean Gate CEO
and his son on the Titan the Minnesota
AG warns Target about their obligations
to the lgbtq community a pentagon
accounting error to the tune of 6.2
billion dollars in IRS whistleblower
talking about Hunter Biden in his
investigation as well as an AI saying
that conservative women are happier and
more attractive interestingly enough we
have all of the juicy stories just in
time for Tim to be sick and for me to
take over but let me tell you something
because I still care so much about my
friend who's allowed for me to take the
wheel tonight I'm going to ask all of
you to go over to castbrew.com check
this out all right for for the cost of
one bag of coffee you can support my
sick friend Tim and we will send you a
bag of coffee uh in Thanksgiving now of
course I won't make any promises again
we have a lawyer here you will go there
you will purchase the coffee I can't
tell you if it's gonna have anything to
do with Tim's recovery but I think he'd
feel a little bit better at least uh
with respect to his morale if you guys
purchased some cast brew coffee and also
it's gonna make me look good he's gonna
say look you know shimcast hosted and we
we moved more product than usual what
I'm telling you is I need this I need
this so please cast brew coffee or just
castbrew.com get yourself some coffee
and while you're at it I want you to
head over to timcast.com and become a
member you dirty dogs all right you're
sitting here you're watching this
content Tim has built this massive
platform so he could give you the news
we're very grateful to him
and if you are able to we would
massively appreciate it if you became a
member supported what he's doing
supported his mission and help him grow
out what he's trying to do here which I
think is a good thing and I hope you all
agree you'll also get access to the
after hours show which is going to be
pretty spicy so now that I have
sufficiently introduced the show uh we
have with us today the man who needs no
introduction what's your name again
I
am Tim pool well hold on a second we
can't do this you're you're the legal
expert here are you able to impersonate
him why don't you sue me oh boy I'm not
the one who's gonna do that I'm saying
that like Tim might have a case against
you at this point no actually it would
be the best thing I could do for Tim to
actually speak in his voice
in a way guaranteed to avoid any legal
entanglements whatsoever yeah it's much
appreciated that's why people hire you
issues related to Contagion and where he
has been recently before this illness
yeah yeah of course I'm Ron Coleman I'm
John Coleman uh Ron Coleman the lawyer
on Twitter
I mean there are other lawyers on
Twitter but I'm the fun one it's not the
only one I'm the fun one and I am um so
happy to be here and
everybody gave me little notes little
messages for Tim
and uh I feel kind of like a schmuck
frankly why is that because Tim's not
here yeah oh they give you messages to
pass along it's not like not like get
not like get well soon
well maybe they're Schmucks
I want my friend to get better
casper.com get some coffee we all do we
all right we all do you know what that's
enough out of you that's enough I could
I could go we we have had a no we we
would like to continue this conversation
but uh Hannah Claire she's really gonna
be the one digging into you tonight she
is a very solid reporter at timcast.com
who has a few things to say about that
yeah since the second I walked in it has
been a very frankly aggressive and and
uh pugnacious yep that's me Hannah
Claire aggressive primlo
uh as you can tell I think this will be
a pretty contentious episode and I'm
happy to be here um my favorite part of
this so far has been uh Ron saying yeah
Sheamus sue me and see what those
cartoons will do oh my goodness I I
think that we're we're in for a show
obviously we hope Tim gets better soon
and if not apparently there's a hostile
takeover happening I'm not sure who's
gonna win and by the way I'll just
mention this before you denigrate
cartoons this is this was a phrase that
was uttered at Art School by the
professors they said the painters look
down on the illustrators they say
they're not real artists in illustrators
look down on the cartoonists and say
they're not real artists but no one
tells a cartoonist that because a
cartoonist can ruin your life Ian
Crossland hi Sheamus good to have you on
thanks for having me who's gonna win
tonight everybody's going to win uh when
people go to Casper coffee casper.com
that is and buy their coffee I think if
we can get enough people more people
tonight to buy coffee than ever before I
think it's going to make uh I think it's
gonna make a real statement yeah I think
so too here's another thing you were
wrong in your intro was that right about
CEO of ocean Gate's son died it wasn't
the CEO thank you for fact checking it
was another guy uh that's why you're
here Pakistani businessman wood I think
I got his name right and his son
Suleiman we'll talk more about it on the
show I'm Ian Crossland happy to see you
guys stay tuned we got Serge duprea
yes hi I'm here guys uh hopefully we'll
keep this show on the rails I think
we're doing a pretty good job so far and
the good thing is that without Tim here
after you know several nights in a row
No One's Gonna know if we don't exactly
yeah he's not gonna watch he's never
gonna see this no I mean no one I saw
last night's numbers oh
what do you see tonight's we're we're
picking it back up we're picking it back
up but uh let's get started let's get
started Ian I actually really appreciate
you mentioning that because the
information I had here was was incorrect
I wouldn't want to spread anything uh
untrue here or something almost to the
wrong house yeah well it's it's
obviously um a very very uh sad story
here uh we've been covering this we
talked about this a little bit yesterday
so I'm gonna read a letter that the
Ocean Gate Expeditions a Twitter account
sent out earlier we're not going to read
the whole thing but I think the first
line is certainly worth repeating given
it has the names of all the people who
lost their lives they wrote We now
believe that our CEO uh stocking rush or
I'm sorry Stockton rush shazda dawood
and his son
Suleiman Darwood Harris Harding and Paul
Henry
I'm sorry hey Miss Harding Hamish
Harding that's my my mistake and uh Paul
Hardy
narglet uh have sadly been lost so they
go on to say that these men were
explorers who had a spirit of Adventure
this is of course a very sad story and I
think that we should try to keep
reverence while discussing it a lot of
people on Twitter have been laughing at
the fact that these people died because
they're wealthy and we discussed that a
little bit on last night's show so we
probably don't have to retread that
territory but I want to open it up to
you guys what do you guys think about
this what do you guys think about the
fact that the Navy says that they heard
or detected that there was a whole
implosion several days ago and didn't
say anything until now whole whole whole
implosion yes because when I first heard
you I thought you said whole no no no
yeah yeah I'm not sure what that would
even mean no because the hole is
yeah yeah like a complete the whole
cracked and they found debris I think
about a third of a mile from the
wreckage of the Titanic so
the Wall Street Journal is reporting
that this U.S Navy technology that's
used to find enemy submarines picked up
on what they now believe was this
implosion around the area where debris
was now found and doesn't that answer
the big question to at least one
possible non-conspiratorial answer to
the big question everyone's asking now
believe now we found the debris now we
know what that weird noise was
true well this is something we were
talking about a little bit before the
show but there there's something curious
about the fact that they waited to
release this information until after it
was already made public that the debris
had been found and so people have been
speculating about why that's the case I
can understand why they might not say
anything because it's possible they
didn't know initially what the noise
actually was and now that the debris has
been found they can confirm that it
actually was the the submersible
imploding and they would probably have
some concern about dissuading Rescuers
from making attempts by telling them we
heard something that very well could
have been this craft being destroyed by
the water pressure or releasing
information through the media when
really these people have families who
probably want some dignity and some
privacy while they learn possibly that
they've lost you know family members so
the Navy's claiming that they I think
was the Navy is that who it is detected
they detected the implosion on Sunday or
shortly after they lost contact I think
maybe on Sunday and then they let a
global initiative to search and rescue
go on without telling people hey wait a
minute uh maybe because they found I so
I'm having a problem with this it's a
very emotional story there's five people
dead which is which is and then their
families and God but I haven't seen the
debris I don't trust the news if they're
gonna tell me that this thing they know
now it implore they're very Almost sure
that it imploded and they found the
wreckage like show me the evidence man I
don't buy it I don't buy this I don't
know what's going on I don't know why
this was made it's like you don't
believe the government yeah
what is this there's like this that I've
been divided crazy corruption scandals
about the president's son but all of a
sudden this new piece of of Pop news
takes over and and they're trying to
like shove it down my throat for five
days uh so I'm curious what do you think
happened here then if you don't believe
that this craft was actually destroyed
by the water pressure or faulty
construction uh for all I know it's
still out it's still down there and they
all died a really horrible slow death
and they don't want to put that in the
news what do you think their motivation
would be for wanting to keep that up
they want to make they want to raise
morale they want to be like they all
died painless because I saw Mike
cernovich tweeted out they all had a
painless death don't worry about it
everything's okay I remember they said
that about about uh the space shuttle
and the Challenger was a lie that it's
interesting that they would lie about
something like that what happened with
the Challenger
they had a voice recording of the last
minute because it started getting hot in
there
it didn't just break off it started
getting hot in there I'd rather not talk
about it we've had enough awful yeah you
have to dredge up awful news from 35
years ago it was
whatever the hell was sure 1984. you
know I think it was no no it's 1986 86 I
was in second grade well it was 86.
Hannah clear you made this point earlier
about dignity the fact that people had
died that they lost their loved ones and
there's a media Fiasco around this it's
an interesting exploration because we
want to look at these issues we want to
know what's happening in the world and
it's good that people were rooting for
these individuals to live you know the
public at least the the
pro-social segment of the public who
aren't just completely out of their
minds and would celebrate the death of
somebody simply because they're wealthy
we're rooting for this family but I
think I think you're on to something
with what you're saying about the fact
that there's a level of sensitivity that
needs to be considered here and it goes
beyond simply saying I acknowledge
something horrible happened here there's
an element of discretion that is
necessary yeah it reminds me of and I'm
low spring up a completely different
political point but uh when Biden
withdrew troops from Afghanistan right
we lost 13 Marines would you want those
Marines names to be released in the
media or would you want their parents to
have a chance to hear it first right
it's it's one thing we're all outraged
by tragedy or we we want to to know what
the end of this uh submarine Saga is on
the other hand real people have lost and
there has to be a slight time delay to
deliver that information now I don't
know that that's necessarily the case
here like we're saying if the Navy
picked up on some kind of sound what is
it going to do say we think we heard
something but we're not sure but maybe
like it doesn't it doesn't necessarily
serve there's no reason to believe they
didn't deliver that information to the
powers that need to be the Coast Guard
whoever's searching again I I agree with
you in here you have to remain a little
bit skeptical I think what we're seeing
a little bit now is uh the question of
why did we finally get this information
today that there is debris that we don't
think that there was an implosion and
what else is going on in the news media
that that would indicate this uh this
morning the news alerts I was getting
were saying you know today is the last
day that they would have oxygen so there
is a reason why this sort of yeah it's
Crescendo today we knew after today if
they weren't found things were Bleak no
matter what well I'll also say this we
know and based on what you were pointing
out earlier about the Challenger Mission
and the catastrophe there that the media
has covered up for organizations to make
the fact that people died horrible
deaths seem less tragic by claiming it
happened quickly and painlessly however
I will say one key difference is the
media might have some desire or
motivation to cover for NASA whereas I'm
not sure what the motive would be to
cover up for this small organization
that doesn't really seem to have any
connections to state or media especially
when usually they're uh I feel like the
federal government is very against
independent exploration right I mean
this was all uh Elon Musk and uh and
Richard Branson's efforts to get to
space I don't think uh the federal
government necessarily was was rooting
them on they see that as their right and
their uh exclusive uh territory again
private exploration of the sea I think
we stopped thinking about it because we
became focused on space but I'm sure
there are reasons that people want to uh
plunge to the FC ocean and see what's
there it really is a world unknown to us
and I don't think necessarily these
people who have the money to do so we're
wrong for taking that risk it's just an
incredibly sad situation we I think I
think it's hard to see these videos on
Tick Tock or reels or whatever where
people are kind of laughing at it
because you want to remind yourself that
like these are people who died and
someone is grieving them and I'll
mention this I think you're correct in
saying that when it comes to exploration
of parts of the world that are currently
Uncharted there is a nobility in wanting
to take that Venture on however in the
coming days or weeks there are going to
have to be some questions asked about
the particular risks that Ocean Gate
took in their construction of this
vehicle and placing people on it and
whether this was the best constructed
craft because there's been a lot of
discussion about that but maybe now is
not the time I heard there was a waiver
they signed someone on Twitter and this
is All Inked all I don't have the Tweet
but they said that they had ridden with
Ocean Gate a year ago and to the Titanic
actually and back and they'd signed a
waiver and on the front page it was like
you wave just in case you die and they
said they said death three times on the
front page could be hyperbolic but
they're pretty much like I think maybe
these these people so I actually heard
so my friend um uh legal legal mindset
Andrew Esquire YouTuber uh did a very
good video that I think he posted yep 12
hours ago today
um addressing potential legal issues
that are raised by this tragedy and
going to your point again
um because of I think what is generally
a government hostility towards
independent well any kind of
Independence and certainly big
Independence like this
um
he seemed to suggest that this is going
to provide an impetus for uh more
regulation but I I'm surprised that he
said that because the first thing he
said in his video and he's I think the
video is great is that
there's a jurisdictional issue here this
is international waters and part of the
reason there it was there was so little
regulation is precisely because of the
lack of a regulating or and enforcing
Authority so the fact that
many countries see everyone knows that
in the world of
sailing the nautical world is if you
have any familiarity at all with the
with with cruise lines they're
notoriously unregulated they are
scandalously unregulated everyone knows
there's a problem everyone knows a
certain number of passengers disappear
are killed are robbed or thrown
overboard and no one ever there's no
accountability
the fact that we know that these things
happen doesn't make them solved they're
not solved so I don't know if this but
but there is some very one of the things
that that Andrew did point out
uh was that you can sign a waiver you
can wave all kinds of things but you
can't there's a level of negligence
of gross negligence that you cannot wave
Away by virtue of signing a waiver that
doesn't give you permission okay now I
can come into your tree house great
welcome aboard Ron I'm going to shoot
you in the head you can't do that yeah
so there will be lawyers looking very
hard at this well uh speaking of lawyers
the Minnesota Attorney General Keith
Ellison actually warned Target about
their obligations to lgbtq individuals
and of course we know that means the
lgbtq lobby that's what they're
referring to whenever they talk about
this community so this was not just the
Minnesota AG there was a coalition of 15
AGS and they reached out to the CEO of
Target to offer support after the pride
backlash in an open letter where they
said and I quote and you know please
stay sitting
um we understand Target recently pulled
some pride merchandise from its shelves
excuse me from its shells out of concern
for worker and customer safety the
letter says that's while we understand
the very dangerous merchandise it's
extremely dangerous merchandise it's
going to jump off the shelves on attack
you yeah exactly it could implode into a
hole oh okay I forgot so they released
this letter where of course what they're
saying to Target is we understand you
know why you were afraid of course the
right wing in this country is just
absolutely out of control you remember
those riots that lasted for a month at a
time that you know that that far right
group must have perpetuated we can't get
to the bottom of it but the Minnesota AG
Keith Ellison road to Target warning
that their decision to pull Pride Merch
this is from Fox by the way
um this is their wording from stores
encouraged bullying in Willen Bolden
hateful methods so hateful methods and
bullying I would say if there was an
example of bullying in this story it
would probably be from the lgbtq
activist who sent bomb threats to Target
but I'm curious to hear all of your
thoughts on this
well we never want to empower bullying
in this country
um definitely the progressive left has
never ever tried to push its agenda in a
manner that would constitute bullying
they would never do that uh I mean I I
think this ridiculous it is interesting
that you know it is a coalition of what
15 attorney generals and the Minnesota
attorney general is there you probably
already mentioned this but uh Target is
based in Minnesota so there's a certain
amount of pressure to get in line fall
in line with your hometown
um it reminds me of the Bud Light
boycott in some ways because initially
it was the conservative saying we won't
drink this Anheuser-Busch you've gone
too far you're pushing inappropriate
things to underage children and and then
on top of that gay bar started
boycotting Bud Light saying how could
you not vocally support Dylan Mulvaney
and everything else that this community
represents and so we're seeing the same
thing here you know Minnesota is now
saying why are you not doing more even
though we will not acknowledge that
you've lost billions of dollars exactly
exactly and so I mean there's just so
much to pull apart here firstly Target
obviously has a fiduciary responsibility
to their stockholders to ensure that
they're not tanking the price of their
company and the valuation of it so that
the people who have invested their money
in them aren't you know completely Sol
and that's not something Mr Ellison
is particularly concerned with as it
turns out no the obligation is to the
lgbtq community here uh and what they
were saying of course in the the letter
was that they understand that there was
a legitimate threat to the safety of
consumers at Target no it was it was the
consumers who said they were no longer
interested in what Target was pushing
here that's the problem what they're
upset about is the fact that people were
willing to stand up to this massive
Corporation and say actually we're not
interested in having you force this
nonsense onto us and our families and of
course they call that a threat to their
safety and then they try to turn around
and say this is a threat to the safety
of our customers this is a very
um textbook left-wing tactic to just
project what they are trying to do is
have a predatory relationship with their
customers where they force any idea or
perverse set of lifestyle choices onto
those customers and they do nothing
about it so they're the ones who are
actually a threat to the safety of their
customers they're the ones trying to
victimize them in a very real sense when
those customers turn around and leave
they say well the customers are actually
being victimized by virtue of the fact
that they're no longer shopping in our
locations because the only explanation
for this is is Big Bad right-wing
terrorist or whatever other Boogeyman
they want to invent to avoid
accountability here yeah I I wonder too
it's just so arrogant of these attorney
generals to not acknowledge that by
telling Target you have to keep this
merchandise on your shelves for everyone
to then take pictures of and share how
it's not selling uh I mean I I think
about one of the best things Alex Stein
has ever done is go to Target and try on
their tuck friendly swimsuit right like
they are I think Alex also feels that
that's one of the best things he's ever
done too yeah I think it's not burned in
my mind actually yeah I still never
forget it his his feet is really really
changed since that experience but I just
mean you know when we again I'll draw
back to uh Bud Light what did we see for
the weeks afterwards pictures of these
these stacks of Bud Lights not moving
off shelves and we saw more cases of Bud
Light with these crazy coupons saying
basically please we'll pay you to take
this uh I I can see on a number of
levels why as soon as this happened
Target felt like it needed to pull the
merchandise into to say was there really
no aspect of bullying and number there
was is this a complete fantasy is it the
way you described it it's a total fan no
it's nonsense their idea of bullying is
you didn't comply with what I told you
to do you didn't obey me that's what
bullying means to a leftist were there
were there even I mean for example the
school board The Bullying advice exactly
the parents bullying the teacher so yeah
Playing devil's advocate which I'm often
paid to do you're a lawyer yeah I get it
um
if parents become unruly or they refuse
to respect you know everyone gets two
minutes to speak and you went over or
you you're Matt Walsh and you're too
effective and compelling you know
but there there's a sort of an immediacy
and there's a sort of a menace I'm
in the most I mean this is pure
democracy in action but is there
anything even comparable to that were
there any pickets anywhere
oh in front of Target stores I think
people it's possible but my
understanding is what they're really
concerned about is just the fact that
people have stopped shopping there and
their stock prices plummeted I don't
know if they would be as concerned about
protests but I think and I think a lot
of this is I think a lot of what's
happened with Target a lot of what has
happened with Bud Light isn't that there
have been you know right-wing
organizations getting protesters
together it's just that ordinary people
have said we don't want this anymore and
we're not going to purchase your product
well not just that we're not going to go
to your stores whenever you go whenever
you go to a Target what do you see
people there dragging their kids along
because these are people who most of
them are caregivers and also people
don't work anymore so everyone's there
with their kids and all of a sudden kids
are looking at these displays and these
bizarrely configured you know articles
of clothing and asking very awkward
questions
and what they want to have happen is for
is for the normal to become
you should your your children should be
exposed to this your children should ask
these questions and guess what we'll
even tell you how you should answer them
exactly that's exactly right
unfortunately consumers still have the
power to boycott these organizations and
they would love to see that stop
unfortunately there are organizations
that we don't have the power to boycott
segwaying into our next story about the
United States government and the
Pentagon so you may have heard over the
past several days while we've been
taking a break from from Tim cast at the
Pentagon had a little bit of an
accounting error which resulted in an
extra 6.2 billion dollars for Ukrainian
military aid you know I really wish that
every now and again one of these
accounting errors could result in the
American people getting tax cuts or
money being returned back to us but it's
kind of fascinating how these mistakes
seem to happen in One Direction so the
Pentagon said Tuesday that they
overestimated the value of weapons sent
to Ukraine by 6.2 billion over the past
two years uh and I don't know I'm
sitting here thinking we can't afford
not to spend an extra 6.2 billion on Aid
to Ukraine and apparently they can't
afford not to have it because we're
still sending it over there they still
get to keep it and there's absolutely no
accountability I mean I can't imagine a
strategy more foolish for determining
how your National Defense or even just
expenditure is handled by putting it in
the hands of people who pay absolutely
no price for horrific mismanagement of
those resources well that's the theme of
our era is no accountability and
certainly no in the federal government
is ever held accountable
for things that they're quite rationally
expected to be accountable for
I was saying before the show as we were
uh you know talking about this that I'm
surprised the Pentagon even bothered
coming up with this story yeah since
when do they even care since when they
need an excuse usually they just say we
just decided to send some more they've
failed their last five consecutive
audits I mean they're still in business
yeah exactly can you imagine let me ask
you this as a legal expert are you aware
of any large corporations that have
failed five consecutive Audits and just
been fine business as usual
well failing an audit is a funny concept
you know I mean when when audits there's
that lawyer talk when audits when when
questions are raised by audits Boards of
directors have responsibilities to
follow up on those and they have a
fiduciary obligation to shareholders to
make sure that problems are addressed so
you're you're asking the right question
the problem with government is that it
is not only
a word for how people doing stuff
together yeah that's right that's what
government means it's just when we get
together or and it's not even just a
word for remember when we all got
together and accidentally gave Ukraine
an extra 6.2 billion when we all just
got together and did that that's what
government is what I'm kind of wondering
here is one of the things I've kind of
heard recently was that they
a lot of the stuff that was sent to
Ukraine it was actually was actually
the military was kind of happy to get
rid of it a lot of it was was outdated
stuff and you know it gives them an
excuse to replace those things with
interesting new and better stuff
uh and maybe it's like a clearance sale
but for military exactly right got to
get rid of it yeah gotta get rid of it
by shooting it at or we're having we're
not shooting it of course we're not
shooting it these people are shooting it
it Salvage their independence and their
pride did not mean Pride this story
but you did uh Dory reminds me I don't
I don't know whatever I saw on Twitter
of like it comes up every tax season
where it's like the government you owe
me money me okay how much we can't tell
you that's right is it this much no to
jail like exactly this doesn't make any
sense to me because the government gets
to be like let's stick this place six
billion dollars in that conversation
because I think we will be coming back
to it tonight again also I wonder if the
if it's an inflationary thing like they
they gave technology over which two
years ago when they signed the paperwork
it's yours was worth 6.2 billion less
and today they're like oh well the
values now or if they're just priming
people imagine a business imagine Amazon
calls you up and says remember when you
bought forty dollars worth of worth of
underwear yeah right it was 60.
crazy crazy we're just claiming that it
was worth 60 after they sold it to me
for 40. well or if what they're doing is
priming us for another uh announcement
that they gave 40 billion
um of an accounting error see for me
it's like why it's the federal
government right if they had just been
like and then we decided to give them
6.2 billion dollars yeah don't like
that's they would have done that to me
this means they knew that they were
gonna get caught for some reason like
they only admitted it and got out in
front of the story the government does
not do things afterwards
what would have happened exactly oh no
we we failed you taught me let me see
your wallet sir like every single time
like I said they never pay any price
single what are you gonna do about it
that's that's exactly what I was about
to say sometimes I wonder if there's a
little bit of
rubbing people's faces in these kinds of
situations I I almost wonder and I know
it's a bit conspiratorial but if they
come out and they admit these things
because
they just want to confirm that you're
not going to do anything about it
there's not really going to be any
backlash well that's the FBI
that's the FBI
yeah we uh
we you know that whole uh
secret Court thing where we're only
supposed to you're supposed to trust us
and
that issues
I typically blew that I mean we just it
well we would I don't know we were
drinking I don't know what it was it was
a someone made a dare I don't but we we
took a lot of stuff a lot of secret
confidential stuff that uh we shouldn't
have taken but whatever right well and I
mean that the FBI has admitted to far
more horrific stuff than that too I mean
FBI and CIA when you just look at the
things that they've leaked you go I'm
glad that they were transparent about
this but not to get too sidetracked
hearing about things like you know MK
Ultra or
um project Northwoods any of these
things that were going on behind the
scenes that if the American people had
known about them at the time they uh
might have actually attempted some kind
of coup and then you you go well they're
telling us now and they're also telling
us that they would never do anything so
horrible again so I guess everyone's
just kind of kind of roll over and obey
the regime I've been thinking about
secret police lately like it's secret
police and they've been thinking about
it well they are the FBI the CIA secret
their secret police
um we've had them for 100 years secret
police are okay if they're not attacking
themselves like if they're not attacking
their own government but when it starts
to invade an attack it's like an immune
um response it's like uh what do you
call what's like HIV it's uh attacks the
immune system immunodeficiency so this
is like an immunodeficiency when the
secret police turn on itself so like the
fact that it's going after a republican
candidate for president for instance
or whatever tapping people's phones in
the United States like that's a and the
Nazis had a secret police that went
after itself they started going after
their own people so like we gotta I'm
I'm okay with allowing a CIA to exist
psych a lot like spiritually even having
a secret police force I understand there
is value massive value to that but uh to
protect our our species in our
environment but but man when it goes on
itself that I don't know how to make it
not go on itself either once it if it
starts like how do you how do you turn
it around without having it gutted you
know when you mean go in on itself what
exactly are you saying like if it starts
to arrest other other people within the
political system of the country that
it's supposed to operate actually was
most prevalent in um the nkvd in the
1930s and and the the astonishing thing
that Stalin among many of the many
astonishing things that Stalin achieved
was
he gutted the leadership of the nkvd
what's the nkvd that was the predecessor
of the KGB
same exact thing I mean he would
sometimes split them into different
Ministries internal external but the
bottom line is so you know Soviet Secret
Police
were turned inside out
and it had been understood pretty much
you know since Lenin and through the
early purges of Stalin that to be what
they call the checkist was to be a
uniquely privileged person you were the
elite and yes
from time to time the number one guy
would get his head chopped off but yeah
being a dutiful checkist was still a
very secure and then all of a sudden
those had and and it was an
extraordinary ex um implementation of
power on Stalin's part to be able to do
that and not result in in a you know in
in a kind of rebellion there because
there were so many different
internal monitoring systems of the
internal monitoring systems that you
never knew
which circuit you were pulling on you
know which wire you were pulling on it
is
so it can be done and you know it the
more power and in fact the more powerful
and invasive your security state is the
more likely that is to happen
that is that a strong man can can start
picking it apart without it realizing
that it's being just destroyed or or
even capable at stopping itself from
being although I'm not sure that the CIA
as such or the NSA or the FBI have
really suffered
any
harm themselves from themselves American
Security has exactly yeah well and
that's and that's gets back to the
course Tim's voice exactly we know
exactly what happened but you know Ian
you were talking about these agencies
turning on themselves you were talking
about some examples of that and it goes
back to what we were saying earlier
about these organizations not really
being held accountable so the NSA the
CIA the FBI I mean in theory You could
argue that like at the very least the
FBI may be a federal police force again
I don't love the idea I'm not saying I'm
in favor of it but if you just wanted to
make an argument for a kind of federal
police force existing well what you
would need to do is create a very strong
incentive structure for it to not go off
and that would do things that are
against the interests of the American
people the church committee which none
of you will remember but you've heard of
which investigated the MK Ultra stuff
and the spot you know the domestic
spying was supposed to resolve that and
what they didn't count on was that
Congress would
completely drop the bow on its oversight
and also
you know what the you know the post 911
security you know uh and secrecy reforms
so to speak the legislative permit that
was given to the security state to
essentially operate
with a degree of comprehension that
would have been inconceivable in the 70s
when the church hearings took place and
which uh are incredibly invasive and
there's no accountability yeah do you
think that we need these agencies in
today's America like should we terminate
the FBI
to your point I I can't imagine
competing in the global world the global
world as opposed to the the flat one
which is yeah well I was gonna say we
don't talk about that until the after
show all right you saw what happened all
right don't make it happen again
I don't see how you can not have it but
on the other hand
I don't see how you you must they must
be accountable and time to say the
cliche who watches the Watchers well
exactly well and this is the thing right
they are watching everybody else so you
look at the FBI the CIA the NSA and all
the mass data collection that's gone on
the fact that they have information on
literally anyone who could ever
potentially stand up to try to regulate
them it seems to me you're either going
to need a squeaky clean person in
politics or someone in politics who
doesn't care if they get exposed and
have their life ruined or somebody who's
both of those things or they're just
going to keep doing whatever they want
to do forever because even if you do
find that person or enough people who
fit that description it's still a long
shot I don't want to be too black pilled
about this but these agencies are
incredibly powerful there's there is a
reason they were able to have the
information come out to the American
people that they were literally with the
Joint Chiefs of Staff plotting against
the United States by planning a false
flag attack or you know with MK Ultra
doing Secret experiments on American
citizens uh and still continue to exist
right it's because they're pretty much
impossible to get rid of at this point
and and you know the question of let's
say you you were made King for a Day
right so you had the power to disband
the FBI
that might not be such a great idea
because now you have a lot of people
with a lot of sensitive information and
a lot of powerful tools
who are unemployed and are looking to
sell what they know they're looking to
become Freelancers and we're not going
to put bullets in the back of all their
heads the most the vast majority of them
are respectable people and they have
their own they have families they feel
like they're doing their Duty
I think we have all been disabused of
the notion that they are
you know won't do whatever they have to
do to maintain their jobs and as I said
last night you know their pensions and
fine but be that as it may you can't
just wish you just can't wish that away
and and it is extremely it's a
ratcheting effect very hard to imagine
how you loosen how you loosen that and
by the way we do have
serious rivals on the world stage as
well as serious problems with crime and
with
uh you know and and with cyber security
both internally and externally and
corporate Espionage you do need
sophisticated
help government is very well positioned
to do that and I've never been the the
biggest libertarian in the world could I
make I bet if Tim were here
he could make an argument you know along
the lines of private you know
privatizing those kinds of services if
you've got if you're a corporation and
you have information needs to be
protected or if you're a person that
needs to be protected move out to uh
Maryland along the the border of West
Virginia and you know that's everyone
can do that uh but be that as it may I
think there's a very strong consensus
and by the way this is another point the
vast majority of Americans don't know
that there's a problem yeah well
speaking of it you were kind of
mentioning these sophisticated tools of
analysis well there are some stories
that we can get to the bottom of without
very sophisticated tools or even Minds
which are very analytical very very
special segue happens
just you wait guys I almost stuck the
landing and then you had to make fun of
me at the end of the show eighth rate
his best segues and his worst segments
we're gonna make we're gonna make a time
stamp exactly after the show we're gonna
do a compilation of of my best and worst
uh Segways well I'll just drop the name
of the story I'll just drop the title
The the article here and the story we're
going to talk about U.S funded
scientists were among three Chinese
researchers who fell ill amid the early
covid-19 outbreak identification of
three who worked at Wuhan Institute of
virology fuels suspicion for proponents
of lab leak Theory that's quite an
understatement a prominent scientist who
worked on Corona virus projects funded
by the U.S government
okay do I have to keep reading is one of
three Chinese researchers who became
sick with an unspecified illness during
the initial outbreak of covet 19.
so maybe it's whatever Tim has maybe
someone else had to take over his
podcast for a day I have no idea but
what I will say is this we have had a
number of conversations on this story
about lab leak hypothesis first the it
came from a bat that lived a thousand
miles away from where the virus first
sprang up Theory which I guess a
nickname we could give did that a
shorthand it stupid the the insane
stretch I I don't know what else to call
it we have had conversations on the show
about the fact that there are certain
theories
and that we as the American people
didn't have access to because
information was withheld from us this is
an example of the American people having
basically all of the facts that they
needed to have to come to the correct
conclusion very early on but the media
just continually gaslighting people
about drawing the most obvious possible
conclusion the reason the term
conspiracy theorist is so effective is
because what it does is it generates an
image in the mind of the person who
hears that term of an individual who
doesn't go for the most succinct
credible reasonable and simple
explanation but who instead will make
any kind of logical leap or stretch to
believe whatever it was they wanted to
believe in the first place now to me
that sounds a lot more like that
description fits somebody who thinks
that covet sprang up in a population of
bats that live a thousand miles away
from Wuhan as opposed to having come
from the virus Factory where they were
doing gain of function research in the
city where the virus first sprang up
for our good for our good how can you
question science I know I know and and
with details now emerging I mean I I
just have to laugh I'm glad that this
story came out I'm glad that this was
published I think this is valuable
information for the American people to
have did we need this did we need this
information to come to the most obvious
possible conclusion here
uh well I I think it is important that
we start to find out agreed who's funded
by the U.S government including if
Chinese researchers were being funded
and getting sick in were they working in
the the covid uh Factory the Wuhan
Institute yeah they were they were
working at the Wuhan Factory where they
were working on covid and they got ill
being funded by the US government it
smells obvious it's insane it's notable
that it's coming from the Wall Street
Journal right this isn't a fringe group
that's exactly exactly what I was
thinking is that okay is this going to
be another Fox Hat oh no it's not
Journal it's not Newsmax it's no one who
also so frankly I don't believe it it's
Wall Street Journal but it's not the
whole street journal editorial page
either yeah it's no it's the they are
presenting it as fact they they feel as
though they have the evidence to back
this up and I I can't speak specifically
to the Wall Street Wall Street Journal
but most of these major mainstream
Outlets we can kind of guess what their
track record on this theory yes are they
cited the fact that this is being
reported I mean we are three years out
some a lot of people's attitudes towards
uh the pandemic have really shifted uh
but it's notable that I I'm I now I'm
very Pro you're foreign
they might try to convince the American
people to be in favor of it just so that
they don't have to take accountability
look maybe this was a good maybe we
needed this we don't want to spend more
time at home
bodybuilder no but
yeah like you're saying maybe we all
already knew this information maybe this
is drawing uh forth the conclusion that
a lot of us had already assumed but the
reason the answer to your question is no
is is that read that last sentence the
identity and role of the researchers is
one piece of intelligence that has been
cited by proponents of the Judgment that
that's actually not very good writing
the opponents of the Judgment that the
pandemic originated with a lab leak and
that is not a an award-winning sentence
but no it's still they don't actually
take the position that this tends to
prove or this proves that it was always
that it was anything other than
a lab League the nature of their illness
hasn't been conclusively proven yeah so
it's just a bunch of facts we're gonna
line up but we can't say what happened
yeah exactly I mean again there's one
extremely obvious now Tim would not
appreciate if we got him do you
monetized no no so this is one of those
things you are able to discuss but we
probably shouldn't push out further into
other questions of the medical science
that YouTube would yeah not questioning
science we're questioning them all
sweets
when I talk about the Medical Science
too I think well there are certain
elements of it that you're not allowed
to discuss because that's you know uh
how science works but I know that with
this The Establishment is actually
starting to admit that this is clearly
true that's what I'm thinking this is
what the vibe I get it seems like people
are like okay we've kind of figured out
what happened and now these news
organizations I don't want to speak for
all of them but the ones that relied for
so long on printing newspaper are
failing they don't have the income that
they used to have in there they need to
get to break the story so one of them is
going to be like you know what we're
done with pretense print it print it
first print it before the New York Times
print it before whoever USA Today just
print it first we'll be the guy now yeah
I think you're right there is a in news
media there's a lot of be there first as
fast as you can and also this is not a
Democrat
Centric story as such
this is the unit party this is the Deep
State this is the administrative this is
the big government so that there's a
little bit more
room for that kind of reporting it's not
like reporting on the bidens yeah yeah
and it actually makes the US government
look kind of bad which might be good for
other countries so who's behind this
news propaganda I don't know that's the
research who owns The Wall Street
Journal then right I wonder how much
money blackrock's put into the Wall
Street Journal let's find out that's a
good question yeah please look that up
for us right now because that's uh
certainly valuable information I mean I
think I've pretty much made my point on
this that the the explanation here from
the get-go was unbelievably obvious
we've had a number of different people
in media and uh in you know the the
channels of the United States government
and actual like uh official institutions
that people look to as authorities
throughout this entire pandemic come out
and say that they were not either being
honest with us from the beginning but
maybe a better way of putting it is
saying they weren't being truthful
because that doesn't necessarily demand
that we believe that they are being
intentionally dishonest just that what
they were saying clearly wasn't true so
there are certainty against the lawyer
the lawyer the lawyer appreciates me
saying that because you just hit on
something that I actually had wanted to
say before but I've forgotten which was
misinformation the information they want
you to miss oh I like that thank you
misinformation
is a made up word
there's disinformation
disinformation is an affirmative attempt
to lie to you
about reality so that you for policy
reasons for political reasons
misinformed I was misinformed they told
me the show started at seven it starts
at eight someone made a mistake or even
someone did it on purpose I was missing
before there was never such a thing as
misinformation I mean there might have
been the formative might have existed
theoretically but
misinformation is something that was
created in the social media era as a
term to describe
what might not be true what might not be
truth but to make it sound like those
who repeat it
are engaged in disinformation because
it's rhymes with and it alludes to dis
information but accusing someone of
disinformation is almost saying that
there are competent State actors or
something you don't want to say that you
want to say rather that they're
interesting so that that's what a lot of
what we're talking about that's the
theme and do you mentioned this you sort
of mentioned it earlier the idea is to
get across an official narrative
and to put to marginalize anyone who
departs from it as being engaged in a in
misinformation not in misinforming
people because when you misinform people
it's like I thought the movie started at
night yeah exactly people make mistakes
no it's because you're bad yeah no I
think that's a very good point it's a
very good way of looking at it I think
what everyone has to remember here is
the media you know social media
platforms and basically everyone in
government including people in
government who are actually colluding
with social media companies that have
them censor people from those platforms
we're claiming that their interest was
in protecting the American people now if
it's true that you are genuinely just a
seeker of Truth who wants to use the
best information available to protect
people then when your track record ends
up revealing that you have been
consistently incorrect about important
details which you punish people for
speaking truth on you'd imagine some
kind of humility would be demonstrated
and you would loosen your grip over the
the control of informational flow or you
would loosen your restrictions and on
some things they have however they still
act with the degree of authority and
certainty which is not only unearned but
what which has been thoroughly
dismissed and refuted by the facts I
would say has been entirely undermined
uh by their own track record it's either
that is that they were uh incompetent or
malicious and either way I'm concerned
with that's why I just don't buy
anything at face value anymore it's
really eroding my will to live I will
admit oh dude like on a yeah like it's
just happening slowly like piece by
piece is coming out of me stone by Stone
I'm like I'm I'm it's getting dark like
the future I don't see a good future in
10 years with this AI Revolution and the
amount of Stranglehold that the US
government seems to be trying to keep on
people like it just admit it sometimes
you know like let it out of let people
live and Thrive otherwise I can't
imagine anything good happening in the
next five years geopolitically I mean
not not nothing but I'm saying
I I don't I mean if if people if they're
willing to shut off people's bank
accounts that are trying to live off the
grid like what the hell are we doing to
ourselves
I'm very concerned man and by the way
the Vanguard group owns 18 of News Corp
which owns uh the company we were just
talking about the Wall Street Journal
yeah Vanguard yeah man
um I I hear a lot of what you're saying
and I think there are a lot of people in
the audience who probably feel similarly
about seeing a very Bleak future ahead
of them but I mean don't lose your will
to live over it you matter I mean you
matter as a person yeah exactly but Ian
that might be part of it it's too much
coffee
maybe you just got so black filled by
that information if you work in news
media and you just consume these stories
back to back back to back it's true it
is easy for it to become like you do you
you have to research the show it gets
really dark on the other hand you have
to remember all the things that happen
in your daily life that are worth
continuing to push against the system
for yeah yeah man so I I I don't it's
just like a psychology hour if I have
kids what are they going to be 20 years
old and shipped off to the military to
fight some war or or like a defensive
nuclear war like I guess robots what
well decide not to push back I mean
that's part of a part of
self-determination right like you have
the free will to be actively present in
the life you have right now and to do
what you can to make the world a place
that you would want to pass down to your
children I think you have to resist
giving up yeah man because you can't
lose hope the The Establishment actually
thrives off of you not having hope when
the people they're trying to subjugate
don't see a path forward that's when
they win that's when they win and that's
part of the attack on religion yup yeah
yep absolutely the attack on religion
and the attack on the family as well you
mentioned something about children again
I don't have any kids but from every
single parent I've ever spoken to it
sounds to me like like choosing to have
children is a tremendous Act of Hope
You're hoping that there will be a
better future you're being optimistic
and saying I'm gonna bring life into
this world because I think it's going to
be a good thing that that I did it was
uh you mentioned to us before the show
that you renewed your faith in your
early 20s was this idea of Hope and
having a path forward something that did
that for you that's a good question I
mean really
you know growing up in what's considered
to be a secular Jewish environment
although it was very strongly ethnic
because of the Immigrant component of my
parents and my and grandparents
you know and then finding myself as
someone whose own parents had not gone
to college and all of a sudden I was at
Princeton so I was in the very precipice
of
in an elite school an elite school and
sort of supposedly the entree into the
elite of the world which is not what I
learned much much later was that these
schools mostly perpetuate that works
they're not there to invite you into
their Network although if you want to
deself yourself enough to really be a
member of the club well that well but
that was precisely that's actually a
Jane Coleman that's my wife's that is my
wife's phrase not that she ever uses it
you know what Woodrow Wilson said the
purpose of Academia is to make a man as
little like his father as possible yes
and that's why his name has been
stripped off every building in Princeton
ironically I think that's honestly I
think that's the one thing he said
they'd probably love right but not not
exactly they've moved away from their
ideological father but the answer to the
question is yes I mean
looking at looking at this strong
identity that I had and then looking at
what really assimilating really meant
and the fact that I knew that I I had an
an inherent
belief in God and in the validity of the
Jewish tradition as
being something that was valid and
meaningful to me it what I did was I
went to uh I went to Israel to study and
became much more knowledgeable about my
heritage and actually took a couple of
years between graduating law school and
starting my career my what would
eventually become legendary legal career
um
to uh did did religion bring some
humility to you uh imagine what it was
like before can you just imagine I don't
think I can no actually well it does not
well that's my much more humbling than
being 25 years old and have a degree
from Princeton and from Law School in
Northwest that sounds really humbling
man and no no and then going to a
beginner's Yeshiva in Israel and
learning
basically the ABCs yeah you know stuff
that my kids learned when they were
seven and eight yeah so that was but the
humbling um effect did pass yes yeah I
know of course well and I'll I'll
mention this and I think we could have a
really fascinating uh discussion about
this and about religion and faith on the
after show but this is one thing a lot
of people are deprived of is a religious
education because parents say you know I
want to let my kids choose when they're
older your kid's gonna make a choice
when they're older regardless give them
an inheritance give them a faith teach
them something so that if they do choose
it they don't have to start from square
one like they're they're like a little
kid learning at all for the first time
and my friend from Princeton days yorum
hazoni writes in his books about
National conservatism and about
conservatism
people are under our misapprehension
they think well why should my child be
exposed to our particular religion sure
he has to have religious education but
what makes our families tradition any
more valid stop asking a stupid question
okay it's your family's tradition it's
what made you who you are do you like
your parents do you like your
grandparents if you don't it's probably
because of Freud throw that stupid ass
tradition out the window based all right
yeah we agree on that we definitely
agree we couldn't save more yeah and I
think we'll save more of it one thing I
would say to people is like when you
start learning about like Christianity
and Catholicism and decide to become
Catholic then don't don't you know feel
free to to not do the same thing
blame the Jews
I want to talk more of the black pill
before and then we can carry the
restaurant because the next story is a
black pill so let's get both of them I
gained a faith in God 10 years ago or so
15 years ago I started to feel it I was
like okay cause microwave background
radiation radio telescopes can see this
web of radiation I'm like maybe this is
God or part of maybe I'm seeing like an
after effect of it or something but then
I'm like okay the last week I was like
oh geez good and evil people are like
good triumphs over evil and all the
movies good triumphs over evil and I'm
like you know what I think most of the
time evil triumphs over good because
it's willing to destroy and then it just
tells people it was the good guy and I
think that's the history of humanity so
even if you believe in God and all these
things that we're supposed to believe in
and have faith it's like then what we're
going to perpetuate this cycle of evil
taking over again and then brainwashing
everyone to think that they were the
good guys it's so pessimistic we'll get
into it on the after show we'll get in
on that show because we have we have
other black pills that I have to feed
people right now otherwise I'd want to
stay on this topic so we will flesh it
out later but uh speaking of humility
we've got a story about Hunter Biden
here the most uh humble member of I
guess we could say our royal class in
the United States at this point
especially when you look at the way that
they're treated I mean no effective he's
he's royalty people it's one of the
number one critiques of uh monarchy and
it's one of the number one reasons
people supported democracy what happens
if you're in a monarchy and the King
just has an absolutely horrible family
unit being ruled by complete degenerates
well yeah Robin Hood that's not a what
if I mean that's literally what is
happening to us right now even democracy
plenty of depravity in the history of
the Roman Empire right amen these guys
they made they they filled up the
history books with some pretty sleazy
moves but we've had we yes we have our
own royal family we wouldn't want them
to get all the glory we would also want
to destroy the reputation of American
people well exactly and so we have
Elites in this country this is something
Ian and I talked about quite a while ago
uh and what I said is the way I Define
elite is someone who will not pay any
consequence for their actions that's
basically how an elite is defined in a
system which is as corrupt as ours is
and when you're looking at somebody like
Hunter Biden and our next story which is
the fact that IRS blowers actually came
out and not just one but two of them and
alleged that there was political
interference and the hunter Biden
investigation talk about information I
didn't need exactly although this is
exactly what I was saying earlier with
the lab hypothesis right there's just
story after story after story of the
conspiracy theorists being proven right
information that we were already well
aware of I appreciate these guys coming
forward I agree that this stuff has to
come out and it's good that they're
talking about it but the fact is nobody
thought this was going to be impartial
or unbiased under the Obama
Administration the IRS was specifically
targeting conservative groups this has
been a biased Organization for a very
long time it didn't start with Hunter
Biden and if it did start with Hunter
Biden it was so blatant and obvious that
basically everyone in this country was
already in a position where they'd be
capable of hearing it without these
whistleblowers that said we're glad they
stepped forward they should be commended
and they should be thanked
the justice department in Delaware U.S
attorney's office went out of their way
to hamper an IRS investigation of Hunter
Biden's taxes by consistently slow
walking the case preventing enforcement
actions by the IRS and tipping off
actions related to the investigation to
Biden's attorneys in advance according
to a new whistleblower testimony
released Thursday by the house Ways and
Means Committee now just a show of hands
who in the room is surprised by this
cricket sound effect yeah exactly it's
weird when there's a story where the IRS
are the good guys like the IRS are like
we're just trying to do our job the the
people disobeying the IRS from inside of
the IRS for the good guys
but it's the justice department in
Delaware attorneys General's office that
are that are slow walking this
investigation they have been I mean
the mere fact that they never acted on
any of this stuff I mean you know that's
the dog that didn't bark I mean it was
obvious and I mean and apparently
everyone knew that that was a
private franchise of the Biden family I
mean this is not news to anyone yeah
well and you look at the fact that Biden
Hunter Biden that is specifically failed
to pay about a million dollars in taxes
and I'm asking you as a lawyer if if I
you know a nice guy like me failed to
pay the government a million dollars
that I owed it do you think I would get
two misdemeanor charges I'd be able to
plead out of that I think you would get
two misdemeanor charges on every square
inch of your body
uh and the felony charges would be
lodged in um other parts of your body
that would be less visible
no okay that's a colorful way of
describing it let me ask what if you
were my lawyer
then you'd you wouldn't even get the two
all right perfect yeah maybe well maybe
that was Hunter's mistaken admire you
you would you would you would get a
Congressional Medal amount I mean I
think it's worth noting that he I'm
surprised Hunter didn't to be honest I
mean it's coming he hasn't gotten it
yeah there's no such thing as a law firm
anymore that works for both Democrats
and Republicans that's over um so yeah
we are I don't know if you might have
picked up on this harmony Dylan thing
but we are a republican Law Firm is
there really none there's there's no
impartial ones for all practical
purposes that's that's I mean in the
upper echelons I mean it might be in
local politics that is that it's still
more you know unpolitical but is that
just since Trump got in Trump was the
turning point
yeah yeah I would say so sorry okay I
think it's worth noting that these this
whistleblower testimony was
pre-scheduled I'm assuming so they
always knew that they were going to
testify on the 22nd and earlier this
week is when Hunter Biden accepts his
plea deal and is like ah yes I did do
something wrong we're not going to talk
about it anymore
um that means they knew this was coming
that makes me think what else is going
to come out again I always think uh
anyone in these places positions of
power or privilege uh try to get in
front of the story so if Hunter accepted
the plea deal on what was it Monday
what other whistleblower testimony are
they trying to prevent from from moving
forward because his attorney
specifically said with this plea Dale my
understanding is that the investigation
is closed like now we stopped
any more questions
it's true but it is interesting that his
attorney's position is now you stop
asking questions Hunter took the guilty
plea we're not going to talk about it
anymore and obviously I don't think most
of the American public agrees with that
uh We've referenced it a couple times
this idea of a a multi-tier justice
system in which Hunter Biden is allowed
to uh you know every report that I read
after he his plea came out was he is not
expected to serve jail time he's also
got this gun charge uh hanging over his
head that is punishable by up to 10
years in prison and he's a white man do
you think he's going to get it yeah no
there's no expectation in her country
that he will go to jail and the fact
that all of us can look at each other
and say it's extremely unlikely that
Hunter Biden's gonna go to jail for
something that anyone else in this room
would be convicted and punished to the
full sex the law is crazy how can uh Joe
Biden who's presenting himself as a man
of the people all the unions support him
middle class Joey calls himself for
himself ignore his way out of this his
son is not going to serve a sentence
that everyone else in this country would
have he played the nepotism card when
they asked him he's going to rub your
nose in it I love him look at it as the
commander-in-chief of the military when
finding massive corruption with a family
member was it's my family member I got
my son like dude you're the commander
you have no choice you have to put your
family member in prison like if they
violate Authority you do what's right
for the country that's why you have the
role no amen
for anyone who would for anyone who
would argue that he should not allow for
Hunter to be locked up because that's
his son and he's in this position of
authority well you know what if your son
doesn't care for the boundaries that you
have to set as a leader enough to not
break the law and embarrass you
immensely when you're the president of
the United States then what do you owe
him lock him up now of course we know
what Hunter owes him and it's allegedly
10 but well I think it's worth noting
that Hunter didn't file taxes in 2017
and 2018. there is no way on Earth that
Joe Biden wasn't considering running for
the presidency at some point in the
years before that that means he knew
that he was potentially going to run
every person who's run for office goes
through uh intense scrutiny he couldn't
have looked at Hunter and be like did
you file your taxes that would be really
good for me if you did that well
Hunter's the smartest guy he knows
that's true which actually the thing is
that actually might be true Hunter might
be the smartest person Joe Biden knows
which is scary which is scary but I
think that might be true when you just
look at his Circle I think that Joe is
going through a state of mind right now
where he's like oh I I did this to
Hunter it's my fault for putting a
memberisma I'm gonna eat this one just
let him go he's not Joe Biden isn't
being punished not being punished so no
one's being punished for this and again
this is not the way anyone else would be
treated and I think there is no way
voters can look at the bidens and say
they are of the people they are not do
by the way I mentioned this earlier but
do you remember when he claimed that
people called him middle class Joe they
didn't mean it was a compliment man no
one ever called you that ever first of
all no one in American politics is going
oh look at the purse in the middle class
can relate to Let's laugh at them that's
not how this country works okay people
who hate the middle class still pretend
to love it while denigrating it
stripping all of its wealth away and
insulting its values no one ever called
Joe Biden middle class jail but you were
going to make a point and I so rudely
interrupted
no I don't think so I think I might have
I I do have this ability to make a face
that looks like I'm about to make a
point but uh if I was I would I don't
remember what it was no actually the
point was I knew it I have to come up
with a point now right he's got a
filibuster till he has a point point was
there was never any concern whatsoever
on his part whether or not he filed the
taxes because he knew that no he's never
been held accountable for anything and
he will not be held accountable for
anything because they have the system
absolutely
right stacked right what if this was
Donald Trump Jr
what would we hear from the media what
would you hear from from Congress what
we hear from the executive branch
there's no way he wouldn't do prison
time we were being totally Adam Schiff
was saying that he had information about
Trump Jr and that he was going to be
thrown in prison and we were hearing all
of this nonsense from everyone meeting
about how the walls were closing in they
were closing in on Donald Trump and they
were closing in on his family and of
course what we ended up finding with the
investigation with the Durham report was
once again something that we all knew
which was that the Deep state was
politically motivated and they were
attempting a soft coup against a sitting
president so when somebody who was
anti-establishment ends up attaining the
highest office in the country in an
unbelievable and unprecedented feat by
being elected president as an outsider
and then the Deep state does everything
they can to subvert the Democratic
process and unseat that person and
everyone in the media repeats a
narrative which we all know was a total
farce to the point where they convinced
the American people to believe things
that are factually untrue to the point
where
of Democrats intuitively to the point
where 60 of Democrats said in a yougov
survey that the 2016 election was
tampered with by Russians in the sense
that they were literally retalling vote
totals now no one in the media openly
said this they just very strongly
implied it for several years and so
that's the treatment that you get when
you're an outsider trying to enter into
the establishment when you are in The
Establishment you can do whatever you
want and you will not pay any price and
if you do it'll be a slap on the wrist
so they can say see we're in partial
Hunter Biden did end up catching charges
he was Prosecuting a court of law
because we gave him two misdemeanors for
something you'd be spending decades in
jail for had you done it yeah
I mean we're done that's everything
that's all of it I think you probably
speak to this better than I can but with
a plea deal both sides come to an
agreement someone says this is what
we're willing to offer you and that
means the US government was like Hunter
we're willing to offer you no jail time
for this like that's bizarre to me this
seems so crazy it's not unexpected he is
the president's son on the other hand I
just think voters should remember this
as they go towards November 2024.
absolutely agreed absolutely agreed and
uh very very very few voters will be
swayed by it yeah that's true I don't
know about that because it was something
like 10 of Voters according to a poll
published by the Washington examiner
said had the hunter Biden laptop story
not been covered up they wouldn't have
voted for Joe I just think it's what do
you think some people will care yeah
that's actually very few though at the
ten percent of them people who voted
Democrat I believe I understand that
it's like seven to ten I I want to
double check on that and it might be
that that might have made a difference
in a couple of Swing States but at the
end of the day what we are saying is at
90 percent
Or democrats would have Shrugged their
shoulders yeah oh absolutely well we
don't shrug their shoulders as many
times as possible you just need to wake
enough people up referencing polls is
risky because you got to find out how
many people it might be that it was like
a thousand people were asked and it was
ten percent of a thousand people said
and the question might have been asked
like had you known that Hunter Biden's
laptop something something where as
opposed to if they just seen the laptop
two weeks ago it wouldn't really have
but when they're looking at the piece of
paper with the question on it they're
like yes I just think under biting
cumulative that's fair but I do think I
agree with you that polls were imperfect
but I think when we have the information
it's important to do something with it
yeah I was gonna say I think just
cumulatively we should look at Hunter
Biden we should talk about Navy his his
daughter who is also he's ignoring like
I think we should all look at everything
Hunter Biden does and say this is the
child that Joe Biden raised yeah maybe
it's not enough to persuade every voter
but I think but is but the real story
though is notwithstanding the characters
serious character flaws of Hunter Biden
and many great families have had
seriously depraved children
and a great deal of wealth can have that
effectively families and especially when
it's
wealth generated by corruption yeah but
the real story going back to our theme
is
this is what Elites can get away with
yes it's what Elites can get away with
and I'll also add this
it's not just that Hunter Biden was
raised in an extremely wealthy family
it's he was raised in an extremely
wealthy family and his father is a
coward and a phony his dad also probably
wasn't around very much I mean if he
worked for 40 50 years in in Congress
he's been in Congress since the 70s
right that's uh that's a long time to be
spending 28 days a month away from your
family he's from Delaware he took the
train home every night yeah he took the
trailer took the train home yeah that's
what he claimed that's good they called
the middle class Joe and he took the
train home every night and he fought
corn to give yourself a bunch of bad
boys he gave himself a nickname so they
called him man they didn't mean it as a
compliment man it's like okay well let
me tell you something Joe this is what
happens to you by the way when when
Hunter is the smartest person who you
know Biden uh was in India alongside the
Indian Prime Minister and he he raised
his hand to his heart because uh
Washington he was oh I'm so sorry he was
in Washington but they were that you're
absolutely correct yes you have the
presidential seal right there
you're never coming back on this
year it's off here's here's well maybe
Hunter's the smartest guy I know at this
point I've just completely uh completely
crashed it okay I want to try again all
right so we're just gonna we're gonna
start again and we're gonna edit this
okay all right no one's ever gonna see
this happen all right so this is what
happens when Hunter Biden is the
smartest person you know Joe Biden was
alongside the Indian Prime Minister he
raised his hand to his heart because he
expected that they were going to play
the U.S national anthem and they didn't
they played the Indian national anthem
of course and Toby
that's harder to foreign
[Music]
that's why video cameras are cool yeah I
think I think this is gonna be the thing
that's going to make people uh realize
that Joe is not who they think he is I
think it's seeing more and more gas but
I mean there's it's like a gaff a day
it's multiple games per day we see like
one up dude yeah remember when he said
he broke his leg because he was grabbing
his dog's tail getting out of the shower
and it's like I don't I don't know dude
this man got elected and then I believe
it was just right after he was
inaugurated he told us he broke his leg
because he tried to grab his dog's towel
while he was getting out of the shower
and his foot I just I like to imagine
most Americans we're we're looking at
that and going oh my goodness what have
we done but I actually don't think so I
I think a lot of them were thinking like
thank God Trump's not in office I know
he might have broke his leg when he
tried to grab his dog's tail getting out
of the shower it's like it would be
worse if Trump was in office exactly
that's a lot of the thoughts right now
is very scary it is very Ron is a very
Grim face uh tell me more
how much do you love Joe Biden on a
scale from one to a hundred
I know love is a vague word but I have
no use for Joe Biden and then one to 100
is too granular do you think that
there's that one he gets he gets a two
there have been worse tyrants than Joe
Byron Joe Joe Byron I like it doesn't
even make it worse than a tyrant do it
you know he's so mediocre
he's a wannabe dictator he's a mediocre
dictator I think he should be a proper
dictator well that's the thing though is
that he's a dictator who you can buy
okay as opposed to those dictators who
you can't even buy because it's a fair
point the dictators who like own the
people with money as opposed to the ones
who are owned by the people with money
very good point I get this Vibe and I
don't have a reference that he's like
functioning as a dictator but doesn't
know doesn't realize it yeah I don't
know I think he realized anything he's
got remember when he said he was losing
his patience with us I'm losing my
patience man like what do you mean your
patience your memory extends five
seconds into the past there's no it's
not possible for you to lose your
patience but he's been a senator not
just a mere member of Congress which is
only a couple of clicks above being a
Milkman okay it's below being a Milkmen
are useful they bring us a product that
we use they're good people yeah good
point speaking of which I just spilled
water on this keyboard flip it upside
down that's the best thing I'm so angry
did you ever see Tim in a million years
Tim would have never spilled water can
you believe live on the show he actually
has it he actually has it no no why Tim
lost his voice
gets a big ego and he thinks I can do
this show Tim you don't see them he's
like you should have done this you
should oh not only that I saw Jack
lastly it's worse than that I got him
sick actually I coughed in his drink I
said I said I'm gonna be the host next
time
you know he he's he's a king he comes in
he owns he absolutely has the moves
Sheamus was thinking obviously anyone
could do this I said I said it's Child's
Play turns out it's harder than he
thinks no I didn't I mean I think we are
there we're I'm gonna return to the
point here because we can talk about
endless number of Joe Biden gas my
personal favorite was when he was in
Ireland and said I don't want to go home
statement did he say I don't want to go
home when he was in Ireland he also said
he's not Irish because none of his
relatives are drunk or in jail well it's
rough and if you're black you if you
don't vote for Joe Biden you're not
black there's rough stuff coming out is
this enough though we're sort of
returning back to the same point will
voters look at this guy and say we can't
keep going he is unpopular there were
polls that indicated a majority of
Democrats felt he was too old to run
again nonetheless the Democratic party
seems to think that they're gonna you
know uh pick him as their nominee at
what point do we look at him and say
nothing you can do matters because you
are going to have the establishment
behind you yeah I'm in that point right
now but I also think hating someone is
not the way to make a better world like
a lot of what got us here was Trump
derangement people that couldn't stand
Trump they'll vote for anything else so
if people hate Biden that much they'll
vote for anything else could be even
worse it could be exponentially worse
and that's why the reason that I say
he's not a tyrant is you know and before
you before you had your confidence
problem over here uh it was that
he's not a dictator he is he is he's a
crook
and he enjoys having power so that he it
can enrich himself he's been a senator
for a generation then he was vice
president which is a job where you get
lots of quirks quirks quirks is
interesting
he gets you get lots of perks and and
queer perks that's what I was thinking
it is pride month yeah a lot uh but the
point is he's used to being the boss
he's used to being the the man and and
he's and he's risen into seniority in
the Senate he you know he therefore he
is impatient
he is short with people he's not bright
so therefore he uses Authority as a
proxy for
the ability to convince people and and
if you you know we all should take a
look everyone before you go to bed
tonight
look at Joe a video of Joe Biden from
the 70s or 80s this was a very very
articulate man not brilliant and not
well spoken as such but the point is he
okay if he's articulate he's well spoken
but he he had the tools to do the job
and they he ran out of gas but what he
became was a useful we have a word in
Yiddish a Golem he became a a zombie an
effective zombie in whom you know a new
SD card could be placed every morning
with that day's you know where to stand
and he has all those you know many years
of of authority but when do you think he
ran out of gas I'm just curious during
the Obama Administration you know I
think you you could see one man coming
in and much less of a man coming out
yeah he used to talk really fast and
sharp even in like 2006 in those debates
with Obama and Hillary Clinton man he
was I mean I didn't like him he was a
chopped liver out of out of Paul Ryan
yeah yeah but then he returned to the
camera because the way he Ryan was
terrible
and Biden he they had and by the way
whoever coaches the Democrats on uh on
debates
years ago they have a thing about
smiling
a really obnoxious thing about smile and
I remember Biden looking into the camera
with these phony pearly whites yeah and
just smirk and boy he's been phony oh my
gosh but but Ryan was helpless Ryan was
like a dear caught in the headlines you
don't think so yeah Biden Ryan uh well
look it's been a long time I mean this
was the 2012 cycle I was pretty young
before still in high school six seven no
he's talking about Paul Ryan I remember
watching it and at the time I thought
that Ryan did better because I wasn't
really impressed by Joe Biden but that
also could have been my political bias
and the fact that I was 17 at the time
but
we've got another story here that I want
to try to push into Pixar the the
Beloved children's film producer which
for a very long time couldn't seem to
miss has been doing worse and worse over
the years and many people are
speculating it's because of wokeness
well now their new film Elemental has
absolutely bombed at the box office
doing worse than any of Pixar's films
have ever done and it just happens to
feature their first
non-binary character so are those two
things related is this just a product of
the new Marketplace and streaming
services it's certainly possible but I
just want to start by highlighting some
of the figures here firstly Elemental
opened to about 29.5 million dollars its
first weekend which is the worst opening
in Pixar's history to be clear Toy Story
made
29.1 million it's opening weekend back
in 1995 5 and it had a 30 million dollar
budget okay so accounting for inflation
Pixar's first film when they were a
totally unknown Studio which did not
have hit after hit after hit and a
well-proven brand blew this current film
absolutely out of the water Elemental
compared to Toy Story's 30 million
dollar budget had a 200 million dollar
budget and not to belabor the point made
the exact same amount it's openings
and face value numbers I'm not talking
about real income I'm not talking about
real Revenue I am not talking about
inflation-adjusted numbers I am talking
about the actual raw figures so they
need to have 10 opening weekends just to
break even on the on the production
budget forget the marketing yep yep
that's just the production budget and so
and money's not free anymore by the way
no it is
I watch a lot of these videos about guys
talking about what representation and
equity and diversity have done to Disney
and to Marvel and what what very few of
the people are talking about is the cost
of capital it's not enough to break even
when you break even you're saying that
the three years that we spent nursing
this 500 million dollars on this project
yep we didn't lose it well actually you
did lose it because the interest on 500
million dollars in the last three years
is real money I mean for you for guys
like you and me it's real money for you
not so much but yeah no not not Ian
he'll he'll be fine but no even for
these massive companies I mean this is
again this is uh another example and
probably the worst example at least for
Pixar in a trend that we've seen over
the past several years and part of it is
these streaming services and the fact
that people know that if a film doesn't
really catch their interest all that
much they don't need to take the kids to
see it opening weekend they can see it
later on but also there is an element I
think of wokeness political correctness
and trying to push leftism in children's
media that has affected the revenue that
a lot of these companies are seeing so
an example we saw about two years ago
one or two years ago I believe was the
Buzz Lightyear spin-off film that was
released and it did abysmally and people
were saying that this wasn't a product
of the fact that there was a lesbian
kiss in the background of the film and
parents were totally fine with that and
they chose not to see it for other
reasons and it's true that some people
might have chosen not to see the film
for for other reasons but the reality is
two of the top 10 highest earning
children's films of all time are Toy
Story films right and then they release
a spin-off film and I'm not going to go
as far as to say it bombed but it
performed very poorly given that
franchise's track record and people may
want to argue if they're on the left
that the fact that there is a lesbian
kiss in a Toy Story movie didn't affect
its marketability or whether parents
would choose to take their children to
see it but I think that's flat on its
face absurd and I think the idea that
parents were in no way affected by a
non-binary character being in this
children's film is equally absurd even
if streaming did play a role
I started out wanted to ask a different
question but I think I think I've
answered that one and I have a new
question
my original question had been at the
beginning we talked about Target
and you know Middle America not wanting
to take their kids into a Target store
because of the freaky things that
they're selling and now we're talking
about Middle America not wanting to take
their kids to a movie theater because of
the freaky things they're selling yep
and in the middle we talked about how
Americans don't give a
they'll just vote Democratic no matter
what and Democratic has completely
embraced the Democratic party has
embraced this entire there's a
disconnection here
the answer seems to me to be
that
General feel-good political allegiances
and voting
are hard to dislodge
and even though we can always find and
do always find
social media sharing
of footage from footage the old man said
footage yeah we developed it in the dark
film okay the video uh of the you know
family-friendly drag show
and you're wondering what the hell
family what parents are taking their
gifts but by and large at the end of the
day most normal Americans
will even vote democratic
will even believe the media and the
implausible
stories that they come up with about
origins of the of you know of covet
they when it comes to
pressing pushing this sexual
sexualization even forget whether or not
it has to do with homosexuality or
transsexuality or any of that stuff
sexualization of children people still
have I think in normal people and that's
still the majority
an inherent
revulsion why does my kid have to be
involved with this at all agreed agreed
I think that's the right way of putting
it it's a revulsion a person doesn't
have to go through like an intellectual
rationalization for why they're not
taking their kid to see that they just
go that's the disgusting I don't want to
show that to my kid they feel it in
their gut and they say this isn't for
our family and they do something else
they don't need to explain it to
themselves I think that's the hard thing
about modern culture for a lot of
parents they're being pressed to say but
why wouldn't you do this why won't you
do that and they don't have a religious
Doctrine to fall back on because they
don't go to church anymore and they
don't observe you know the tennis of
their religion and yet their souls are
screaming within them amen that there is
right and wrong in this world that there
is certainly call it natural law call it
God's but there is morality that there
are things that matter there are values
that are not malleable and people are
embarrassed to be associated with a
religious
um rationale for having those feelings
because what could be less fashionable
well and I think this is why it's so
important to the alphabet people to go
after children because it is true as you
said this is this is written on man's
heart he understands this there are
certain things that are wrong and
when a child sees something grotesque
for the first time they're going to
respond as they are naturally inclined
to I'm not saying everything that we
feel internally is indicative of a moral
reality sometimes we're wrong but in
general especially when it comes to
sexually perverse behavior when
someone's exposed to it they recoil they
find it to be disgusting so the reason
they want to show it to Children is
because what they're effectively doing
is a kind of perverse exposure therapy
which we usually call grooming but of
course because the left wants this
particular form of grooming to continue
they're not allowing people to call it
that but that's exactly what it is we
need to try to expose children to this
and then Gaslight them out of following
that initial internal sense of revulsion
towards the perversity in front of them
and it doesn't have to even be
perversity as I said
the entire most normal young children
are uncomfortable with
outward displays of what we might call
romantic affection they don't really
want to see Mommy and Daddy kissing a
kiss is okay they don't they don't want
to see you making out with your spouse
they do not want any part of that as
they should like an adult wouldn't but
but if you wanted to create a world
where like adults were just making out
in front of each other and in front of
kids and being weird then you'd go to
San Francisco you'd go to San Francisco
no but that's what these groomers do
they they try to expose children to it
as early as possible so that's normal to
them it becomes normal to them exactly
exactly I think it's also important to
mention that a lot of the people that
are performing in Drag and Etc and in
these in these environments I mean I was
a DJ for years and I've been around a
lot of the gay community say what you
will about it but they don't feel
comfortable doing this they don't want
children to be around like that and a
lot of them are in the situation where
they're essentially being forced by
people that are yeah I represent a
couple of organizations
um one is one is a gays against rumors
yes okay great people and these are you
know these are these are real homos
these are in other words these are
people who they're not they're they're
they are they're actually they are
they're actually they're they're you
know it is it is a big part of their
identity another I mean you know there's
like an entire different conversation of
does tolerance of homosexuality require
me to have to hear about your homosexual
interests all the time separate apart
from that what my clients are saying is
they're killing our community yes
they're killing the reputation and the
image we had and by the way
there's a parallel to what's happened
with with race relations in this country
because most of us
until Barack Obama was not only until
Barack Obama was elected
but especially after Barack Obama was
elected but we did it
we on race relations yeah we've done we
have turned that corner we can elect and
that and by the way many many many
people voted for him to demonstrate to
themselves exactly that I'm not racist
they are not right I voted for a black
president and what happened is the door
was opened to a radicalization not
necessarily because of Obama himself I
don't think so but because of people
around him I actually don't have that
sort of really intense
uh hatred of Obama that a lot of people
do uh and in fact you should probably
talk to someone I mean you should get
get that checked out not hatred strong
dislike I strongly dislike him
yeah the strong dislike but continue
continue no I bet but the point is the
point is the the people
thought that we had we sort of had the
sexual Revolution and a lot of morality
moral choices were Unbound and
traditional
and we were not necessarily all of us
that comfortable especially those of us
and who are traditional religionists
fine fine you you know you go and ruin
your own Society
we're gonna just hunker down
it's inescapable now exactly nowhere
they won't let and by the way and that's
always how it Trends by the way they're
never okay doing their perverse thing
and then leaving other people alone to
live their traditional lifestyle there's
never a limiting principle nope and
there can't be because
when their entire argument for
recognition and acceptance and tolerance
is premised on marginalization per se is
an is an evil that means that there is
no margin on in which you can leave the
most
perverse behavior and there we are yep
well it and this is always how it goes I
mentioned this on the show a very long
time ago when I first started doing it
when this conversation came up but this
is uh why I think Henry VIII and Saint
Thomas More are such an important case
study because there was nothing St
Thomas More could really do to stop
Henry VIII from discarding with his wife
and then taking a new woman it was just
the fact that he knew that Sir Thomas
More
disapproved of what he was doing
sexually that made him say I have to
kill this man I have to kill this man is
that the guy where he's like will
someone rid me of this priest was that
the priest no I don't believe so but
that's a similar story is yeah I mean
there have been a lot I mean good
priests end up being sort of a sore a
thorn in the side of a lot of these uh
corrupt rulers so you think Ron just to
understand maybe what you're saying is
that like this this move towards an
openly sexual Society or a a
repressively sexual Society is like it's
a trend and it's never static so like
this whole like the gay rights movement
The Liberation of gay marriage it was
always inevitably tending towards
complete open sexual transparency
towards children and the other the only
other option is to repress it
it it's a very you're you you have asked
the right question and you've identified
the Dilemma because as a First Amendment
lawyer
I'll make it first clear that the First
Amendment does not protect obscenity
but the United States Supreme Court has
essentially defined obscenity out of
existence um
and made it pretty much a consent issue
which has nothing to do with obscenity
whatsoever
we live in a society now where the only
Criterion
had been until just about 10 minutes ago
had been consent and we're now broaching
that as well because there's never a
limiting principle so for so talking
about the sexualization of children and
literally the sexualization and
sexuality involving children
the mere fact that people have the
audacity to
speak in public discourse about
sexualizing children about you involving
children with sex
is a complete abnegation of the of the
concept that children are deemed morally
incapable
of giving consent yeah but we have to we
can't maintain that position because
we're also taking the position we pretty
much you and me not that children can
give their consent
to having their
genitals mutilated and to taking drugs
that will supposedly change their sex
there is no limiting principle yeah
there is no once you say that and this
is meant to be a stick in the eye to God
yeah it's not merely by the way if they
had God no
they are well aware of God like you said
there's a resonance in the universe that
the soul picks up on this is what
Abraham was the first person to do he
says this bowing down to rocks and trees
wrong there's a Creator there's meaning
in this in this universe there's right
and wrong
these people know it
and they feel it and they hate it they
resent it and there it is a matter of
not you know it used to be something
called agnosticism
I don't know I don't know most agnostics
today call themselves atheists because
it makes them feel that they have a
position
usually one that they can't actually
intellectually defend because they have
no familiarity whatsoever with classic
religical religious thinking
or any thinking usually
but that's what it's about it really is
a fight against God as as the entire
transsexuality and transhuman uh
movement look I could not agree more I
think we're gonna have a fantastic after
show segment talking about all of this
stuff if you guys want to see that go
over to timcast.com and become a member
but for now we're going to go to super
chats I am not your buddy guy for five
dollars says our corpse and the stock
market required for capitalism to work
if not is it worth keeping these
Concepts if companies like BlackRock
will always exist that's an interesting
question what do you guys think about
that I was taking a note so someone else
answer because I want to hear that again
I've thought about this a lot
so I'll answer
corporations are creatures of law they
are an artificial
um creation
and in the past Milton Friedman type
Libertarians made the mistake
of assigning to them a sort of value
free
uh
place in economic and economic
philosophical thinking
corporations are just something that
people choose to do together
guess what they're not they're actually
governments uh some of the most powerful
corporations in the world effectively
act much in the way that governments do
and many of them are more wealthy and
some of the of many of the world's
um
governments as traditionally conceived
corporations are a creation of the law a
very very
creative and Brilliant way to raise
Capital if I can avoid liability exactly
if if the way for us to finance this
project
is to separate the the the the the
investment from the liability
that's a deal we'll make okay and we'll
double taxi there's
all kinds of things to talk about
the answer is no there is no reason you
have to have these things for capitalism
to work but if you wanted to work cool
don't work good you want to have an
iPhone
you want to have an internet you want to
have incredible medical developments
that are often wildly uneconomical but
they're there and in theory they might
become before all the things that
American capitalists with all its
dynamism and all its waste and all its
stupidity and all its brilliance
you do need the ability to have Capital
formation on the level of what
corporations do today but there's no
reason on Earth that corporations cannot
be regulated by the state except for one
there is one reason the state sucks ah
the state is the is the problem there
very inefficient so if the five of us
could make the regulations fine yeah
yeah fair enough we fix it
we've got uh thank you for the question
by the way thank you for that that
answer you're welcome I'm rather
exhausted Raymond g Stanley Jr for five
dollars she said Sheamus you made it
buddy you really made it shimcast is
officially official also remember World
War II wasn't that cool yes I did a
cartoon about this a while ago that he's
he's quoting thank you so much for your
Super Chat and for the support the
question is when Tim is ready to take
back over will Sheamus give up the seat
is it going to be a soft coup yeah I I'm
not sure I feel like Tim should return
maybe that's why I spilled the water I'm
trying to prevent him from taking the
helm on the smell
um Joseph no says dude oh this I've
actually been trying to tell Tim this
okay dude Tim liquid death made us made
you sick advertises H2O infused with
real demons homepage has a link to sell
soul and email them the culture War
fight is a fight against demons don't
invite them in pray to God hundred
percent hundred percent that stuff's
horrible I stay away from it also I
understand because this is what people
will say oh they're just worshiping
Satan ironically is a joke I don't care
do you think Satan values sincerity do
you think he wants sincere worshipers
he's fine with you worshiping him as a
joke okay don't no I also I've always
wanted to ask liquid death their their
thing is burn cans because it's death to
plastic but their cans have a plastic
lining yeah so they don't totally this
is a sponsor it's evil yeah I don't
think it's ownership no no they're not a
sponsor but but Tim drinks them and
that's why he's sick important thing to
notice that is uh about the devil needs
him to drink this in order to make him I
don't think so no no I don't think that
no I don't think he needs it but that's
not what that's not what old shim is
saying I'm just saying that you need not
to drink it because the devil's involved
yeah that's what I think I think the
important thing to mentioned about
regarding like the plastic is these are
not like uh in plastic bottles that are
exposed to sunlight that's when that
plastic is then seeping to the water is
when these these bottles of water are
shipped they're outside and exposed to
the Sun and I believe that's when a lot
so when you recycle them what happens to
the plastic this is a conversation for
later but this is a conversation for
never
this is a conversation we'll talk about
maybe maybe Tim was going to blow the
whistle on it and he lost his voice
because he was drinking liquid death I
don't know I don't know
um like her death is going to send you a
cease and desist letter
veldrin olis says wow how sick is Tim
that he let the cartoonist Take the Lead
Let Freedom Tunes rain well thank you
I'm getting mixed messages here because
he's perplexed that Tim would allow me
to host the show but then he's he's
saying uh Freedom Tunes May rain
speaking of which we released a cartoon
today all right it's a pretty awesome
cartoon the fans are loving it and we
have a 30 minute long version of it
behind the paywall it's a web review 10
minute long version on the channel 30
minute version on the paywall
freedomtunes.com I think you guys do you
know how some companies take over other
companies and they refer to it as a
hostile takeover I'm sort of picking
Tim's a very good friend of mine you
know are you sometimes friends get
friends sick so they can do their show
um
but then you would have had a really
good guest not a leftover guest that was
Benford yeah that's true supposedly
meant for Tim no I I asked for you back
I wanted there to be legal help he has
to make it looks smooth and have a good
transition happy to have you back and
this way he doesn't look like he's
totally in control I don't know you guys
said the debris field was found yeah
that's correct uh I think I mentioned
that on the show about a third of a mile
away from the Titanic wreckage we were
told it was found yeah we were told it
was found I'm loving the skepticism but
I do think they're gonna pull it all up
right so we should have photos I assume
maybe part of the skepticism though is
black pilling man like I need something
to believe in I want to believe somebody
yeah um I think both of these men have
things to tell you about then
grafty says Ian you are the same year
birth as me I have the Challenger
Mission scarred in me I remember maybe
we can re we can learn from the Starship
and this sub test
I think we are learning from from these
these things at least a little bit about
how they'll tell you that they died
peacefully do you think it's worth not
going not going where like on any
Explorations I personally will never if
unless I have to get there I will never
take that kind of risk I I can say I I
have a fantasy about like swimming the
Bimini Road and off southeast Asia
because ancient history recreational
risk taking on this scale is
preposterous I'm not that kind of guy it
is it is utterly morally unjustifiable
to to expose yourself much less a family
member
I understand may not have been all that
eager to go I don't know to
um did this kind of literal mortal risk
for Thrills there's plenty of thrilling
stuff to do on the surface on a nice
sightseeing boat or even you want to you
want to dive I mean but to this this of
course people didn't really appreciate
the level of risk
although
uh you know I don't know yeah the sugar
Common Sense fishing says did you guys
forget they found the Titanic by luck
while on a top secret mission to find a
nuclear sub with nukes on board it's
near the Titanic site I didn't even know
that I didn't know that either Oh I
thought I thought they were looking for
that diamond that Rose had
we don't really go in for a lot of
movies good for you good for you I see
was he saying the super chat's saying
that they the submersible the submarine
the nuclear sub found the submersible
because I thought I thought they were
doing voyages to look for the Titanic so
if if is this true that they they're not
defining it doing something else yeah
let's look into that yeah I believe that
what happens they were uh there was an
it was a sub actually down there like a
US sub and then they eventually were
paying off them like whoa this is
definitely something and then eventually
they went and found it again later on
and verified they're fine oh I want to
clarify the Bimini Road is not in Asia I
was thinking of a different uh megalith
underwater megalith off the Southeast
coast of Asia I can't stop thinking
about underwater megalith so I can't
blame you for that yeah I'll find the
name of the road
um Noah prunier says don't mind me this
Super Chat is just me making sure that
the potato man can rub it in Tim's face
shimcast forever thank you thank you for
the Super Chat appreciate it so if you
guys want to send more Super chats in to
make me look really cool how long is Tim
that much richer exactly but it only
look it'll make me look cool how long is
Tim going to be sick for how long are we
doing shimcast how much did you get uh
yeah yeah we'll we'll I'll talk with the
lawyer after this
maybe it's both
very true okay
um Amos Moses said last night I said the
second amendment applies to crackheads
that is not just my not my opinion but
the opinion of U.S District uh judge
Warwick the uh Bruin precedent requires
historical contacts the founding fathers
did not prohibit alcoholics or drug
addicts
shamcast is Best cast well thank you I'm
glad you like uh shamcast uh shim cast
over here I I will say I think there's a
difference between how dare you I think
there's a difference between
um alcohol and crack but I'm curious
what you would say about that do
crackheads have a constitutional right
now let's back that up is there really a
difference between alcohol and crack I
have found myself I'm not asking you
from experience legally does a crackhead
have a right to own a firearm is that
constitutional the person who is
impaired right now in other words not
someone who wants to use crack but
currently you use your crack they keep
cracking their house yeah someone who's
addicted and they currently use are they
are they constitutionally added to own a
gun
there are I do not claim to be a second
amendment okay expert fair enough but
that was wrong
but give us give us your your best yes
non-legal expert answer I think we would
I think the the Supreme Court has never
said that the Second Amendment prohibits
all regulation of firearms let's start
there right
what would be the first tranche of
reasonable regulation that every
reasonable person would agree with
shouldn't give children fire Firearms
well actually many young people do learn
firearm safety in rural areas okay but
you shouldn't give crazy people firearms
is it a reasonableness test I don't
really know but if there's any
regulation whatsoever I mean we we have
legislation that says felons in some
places cannot have cannot have firearms
um
crackheads let's leave out the fact that
by virtue of having crack in the house
you are a felon if you're under Biden
let's say it's not a problem no two
misdemeanors sir tax yeah tax
misdemeanors
that's like that's how they got Al
Capone though right that's how they got
Al Capone those two misdemeanors
oh my goodness I'm not so the the Bruin
opinion isn't is an important opinion
and we we do need to understand that
what it what it is addressing has been a
phenomenal amount of
over reaching by the states and by
municipalities to find ways and excuses
and rationales to regulate
uh firearms in ways that are not
tolerable by the Second Amendment but if
you said that someone is psychologically
unfit to
you know to own arms because of the
because of the risk that it poses to
others I think that's a probably a form
of Regulation that the Second Amendment
would tolerate 11 until the Supreme
Court says you can't regulate it
whatsoever which I don't think they're
going to say uh I would not want to die
on the hill of crackheads can own guns I
am right there with you a crooked smile
says wonder when Tick-Tock is gonna do
the hunter Biden challenge oh boy Dax I
already know it's not going to be good
uh tax evasion and throwing away a
firearm to say the least wonder if the
challengers will get the same Biden
treatment well I think we all know the
answer to that question he didn't even
throw his gun away didn't his girlfriend
throw the gun away is that what happened
really yeah that's what I read I mean
you know it's so unfair I'd be so angry
you know
this this woman felt that whoever found
the gun rummaging through the trash
would be better suited to own it and
Hunter that's how bad it was okay uh
grislock says it's not that 90 don't
care it's that 75 don't even know what
the heck is going on to begin with
censorship mine you didn't say heck amen
oh nice work yeah I think there's truth
in that I think there's truth in that I
think it's more like 68
and that there's a 12 you know I think I
think that's right is astonishing how
much well we heard last night
you know in in the um
you know in the third hour uh
about how
so many people have no idea what's going
on you know so you know people
especially the worst thing a person
could do
is rely on mainstream media
yeah it's worse than not than than not
even reading because it literally it
makes you dumber yeah
um the the moffinator says tired of true
pressure or daily life
Do You Feel Like You Don't Know Jack do
you got hairy legs Dr Mata Kafka
provider to say to see if next I'll
wrestling is right for you
keep it up on purpose I was just hoping
you'd read it like that of course of
course come on I'm not gonna pass that
up come on man
um can you do a Stewie though like Jack
does I mean yeah the blank can register
for books
you're all right along with it
um we have a Aaron smraker I'm certainly
not pronouncing that properly yeah
Aaron Smacker Sheamus the regime's act
of admitting their true intentions is a
black magic practice they will tell you
what is to come and it is up to you to
stop them think the w e f and agenda
2030 or event 201 I'm curious what the
rest of you think of that how do you
stop them I don't disagree that if if
someone's corruptly trying to destroy
distort I don't I don't know one
person's destruction is another person's
creation so like how do you do it how
yeah I don't know and what's the what
are you doing exactly like what how do
you stop like how do you we don't want
to stop reality that means it is done
for everything yeah I would I would hate
that we want to keep going but how do we
change it
um I've absolutely lost track of what
we're talking about oh corrupt
governments how how you how do you step
in and change a corrupt government from
within the country
um
pinochet's helicopter pinochet's
helicopter tours says search for the USS
scorpion that led to discovering Titanic
okay all right so I guess it's been a
second Super chatter is that good then
like we have the Navy out doing whatever
it needs to be doing the Titanic yeah
all about Pandora's Box where now
billionaires getting yeah unstable
submarines and go after it billionaires
are going to do what they want to a
large extent the Lester Donald Trump uh
so Jacob says hey shamers how you doing
firearm industry worker here the Federal
Form 4473 lists question 21g are you an
unlawful user of or addicted to
marijuana or antidepressant stimulant
narcotic drug or any other controlled
substance absolutely correct it does it
absolutely does
um no disputing that so what happened
was on last night's show I said that I
don't think crackheads should be able to
own guns people are actively you know
smoking crack and people were asking or
people were basically saying that the
Second Amendment still protect that my
point is that I think it is reasonable
to have restrictions and what I said
yesterday is when the founders wrote the
Constitution what they said is that you
need a virtuous populist in order for
something like this to ever really be
pulled off effectively and one of the
Hallmarks of a virtuous populace is that
they
don't smoke crack no yeah you can't do
that virtuously yeah what if you do it's
not purchase there's no crack in
moderation there's no like virtuous
amount but then you give to charity
no no but hold on a second then yes
giving to charity or giving to the soup
kitchen would be a good thing to do but
the act of smoking crack does not become
virtuous so judgmental of you I know
never let us have any fun I'm I'm a
really really mean guy Jacob Jones says
Ian it was Henry II speaking of Thomas
Beckett that's right 12th century with
uh won't somebody rid me of this priest
which he said well drunkenly raving
oh wow
jeez don't drunk man's words silver
man's thoughts let me tell you
yeah let's never go back to a monarchy
well we got one
um but just not a cool one would it be
better to have a monitor yeah yeah
exactly this democracy eliminates class
Consciousness it does sorry I totally
cut you off um yeah but at gym gas you
can do what you want well right that's
right better to have a monarchy that we
know as opposed to like a corrupt a
Visage of a democracy or a republic
that's actually run by one guy in a
boardroom somewhere or even if it's not
one guy in a boardroom but it's you know
15 guys you know in in Dave Switzerland
or whatever the hell you know however
you want to imagine
you know the New World Order
if you know you know monarchies have
fallen and houses of monarchies have
fallen have been been replaced I mean
the Henry II was not a a grandpa of
Henry VIII you know there were
monarchies lose you know can can there
can be transitions one of our problems
in fact is um this is light bulb is
going over my on my head right now I
don't know if if your cameras are
sensitive enough to pick it up but
is that we are all so busy in toning our
commitment to democracy that we are
reinforcing the illusion of that
democracy exists
and we need to come to terms with the
fact that you know this elitist this
this
multi-track system of reward and
Punishment
exists and
you know the Democracy perhaps would be
a good replacement for it yeah also well
I'll say this for anyone who's
interested in the the arguments in favor
of monarchy because especially in the
public school system in the U.S they'll
explain to you the benefits of every
system communism socialism all these
horrible destructive ideologies and then
you never hear the other side of the
question with the democracy versus
monarchy debate so Hans Hermann Hapa has
written a brilliant book on this called
democracy The God That Failed which I
would just encourage everybody to check
out it's a really good read very
brilliant
so uh we're coming up uh on wrap up time
it's been really awesome having you with
us here Ron I want to thank you for
coming on to the show and also give you
an opportunity to plug whatever it is
you want to plug my friend you know I'm
Ron Coleman you can find me just when if
you just Google Ron Coleman lawyers
you've got to use the word lawyer you're
going to get the bodybuilder you'll look
for a while and then you'll figure out
it's not the same person as me who can
bench more
well I bench oh is it just a Yiddish
joke it's not even worth it who can
bench for it big Ron Coleman actually
can barely move his arms right now I
think he's he's not a healthy man yeah
but be that as it may uh I'm on
primarily on Twitter at Ron Coleman's
spell it with an a-c-o-l-e-m-a-n and
when you go there you'll find all the
stuff of course not everyone follows me
who ought to follow me on Twitter but
you know they eventually come around and
um
that's all you really need to know I
have a podcast it's called culmination
the joke is culmination finishing
finalization not Coleman Nation but I'm
stuck everyone says Coleman nation which
would be really lame those are your fans
right the Coleman Nation my fan
I'm Hannah clear brimlow I'm a writer
for timcast.com I'm so glad I got to be
here for the union thank you for buy
white writing tonight's episode I mean
yeah yeah
it came across very natural I would say
it was like a fever dream right now I'm
so glad you guys all got the script
because also the characterization was
finite I know your character especially
you guys you guys are good actors you're
kind of leaned in sometimes that was
cool yeah the thing is I didn't get the
script but I'm so predictable that she
was able to write around me
all public figures and I could just read
through your twitters uh so again I'm
here to go Rubble I'm a writer for
timcast.com you should follow at timcast
news on Twitter and Instagram it's great
it has all the work for me Chris Bertman
uh Chris Carr Cassandra McDonald it's
got lots of great stuff uh I'm supposed
to tell you to keep an eye on the trash
House Records uh YouTube channel that's
from Carter Banks our excellent music
guy he's got a lot of things coming up
and he thanks you all for your patience
if you want to follow me personally you
can follow me on Instagram at
handclare.com B and on Twitter at HC
brimlow again thank you guys so much and
I'll see you in the future I guess I'm
Ian croslin have a great night guys you
follow me at Ian crossland.net or Eddie
and crosland anywhere on social media
and I will be happy to chat from time to
time when I see you and I'll see you
on the after show which will be very
soon here my name is serge.com uh it's
been fun it's been an interesting uh
interesting ride that's for sure it sure
feels like uh sure feels like we will
have an interesting after show as well
again I say it again it will be
interesting uh it'll be on uh
timcast.com for those members who have
been members with her for six months and
anyone over 25 membership I think you
are all able to call in even uh join us
there again search.com on Twitter let's
argue I appreciate it
uh despite The Uncanny resemblance I am
not Tim pool my name is Sheamus Coughlin
I have a YouTube channel called Freedom
Tunes today we released a cartoon it was
me fixing left-wing memes for pride
month I had my fans send me a bunch of
memes sent to them by left-wing
activists or that they saw out in the
wild and I subjected myself to the
torture of fixing those memes for you
guys and actually turning these
left-wing memes funny the video is about
10 minutes long and then we have a 30
minute long version behind the paywall
over at freedomtunes.com if you guys
sign up you will be supporting what I'm
doing you will also be supporting my
team of non-woke artists who are really
talented and work really hard to get
these videos done now we're gonna be
heading over to the after show in about
10 to 15 minutes so if you guys want to
go over to timcast.com if you're already
members please tune in if you're not
sign up watch us it's going to be a good
conversation and thank you all for
hanging out tonight
foreign